[Music]
well on this date we are taking you on a
ride with the golden knights
not the hockey team but an elite group
in the army and like a lot of us covet
19 has affected what they do including
recruitment the i-team's vanessa murphy
joining us now live tonight and vanessa
you had a chance to
be a part of the team for the day right
yes i did and you know what training for
the military
is never easy but this group goes
through even more training
to safely jump out of a plane and then
take some people
with them it's part of recruitment which
is happening
even through the pandemic
this is one way the u.s army does
outreach
during the beginning part of kova we had
a downturn and then we're now kind of
figuring out how to get messaging out
again
these are the golden knights the u.s
army's parachute team around
long before the las vegas hockey team
they travel making stops and giving
tandem rides but the pandemic put these
trips and other recruitment efforts to a
halt
we started using digital media platforms
my recruiters do things like zoom calls
with the schools and we coordinate a lot
of things for guidance counselors
an army spokesman says the las vegas
area has had the highest
level of recruitment for the department
of defense over the past
two years only 29 percent of applicants
make the cut
the biggest disqualifier obesity but
food allergies certain piercings and
health issues like asthma are
disqualifiers also for those who do make
the cut
i initially started off as an 11 bravo
infantryman
there are opportunities like this ask
them what it takes to become a gold
knight and
i started working towards that staff
sergeant daniel osorio
is now part of the elite team he
describes the challenge of 2020.
so initially it was it was shut down
just like everything else
as restrictions started to become get
lifted
we were able to get back into jumping
safely of course you know
we're wearing face masks practicing
social distancing and then we were able
to start traveling more
part of his duties taking students with
him the goal is to connect the army to
the american public
on this november day the team is hosting
educators police
and media sign up suit up and then pair
up with
an army videographer well you dress a
little funny what are you getting ready
to do
jump out of a plane then heading to the
plane with staff sergeant osorio for a
ride
two and a half miles up
buckle in with staff sergeant osorio
and a jump a free fall at a speed of 120
miles
per hour with a view of southern nevada
this is staff sergeant osorio's 3017th
jump parachute deployed
and a smooth landing it was awesome
and thank you so much for dealing with
did you know you're nervous at first
danny put a big smile on your face
you're like let's do this an
unforgettable ride and a way in which
the army hopes to reach
future soldiers
and almost changed my mind but staff
sergeant osorio helped me out and we
made the jump special thanks to
him and the rest of the golden knights
we've more about them
at 8newsnow.com and they do more than
just take people for
rides they actually do stuff like this
show you guys they make formations
in the sky it's pretty incredible again
we have more about them
on our website reporting live vanessa
murphy 8 news now